من الرياضه الى التقنيه طبعا من ميسي الى
ايلون ماسكواتساب لا يمكن الوثوق به هذا
مقاله ايلون ماسك الذي يضرب مجددا في
تغريده انتشرت بشكل كبير على مواقع
التواصل تغريد طبعا يستكمل فيها ماسك
فيديو نشره مهندس يعمل في تويتر قال ان من
صه فيه اثناء نومه
واتساب اهتمت بالرد وغردت قائله ان سبب
ربما يكون خطا تقني ليس الا وفي تغريده
ايضا منفصله قالت ان لانها تستخدم
الميكروفون الهاتف فقط عندما يقوم
المستخدم باجراء مكالمه او تسجيل لكن
واتساب تحارب في جبهه اخرى اشرس بكثير
تحديدا في بريطانيا ضد مشروع قانون الامان
الجاري اعداده هناك ويعمل على التصدي
للارهاب ومحتويات الاستغلال الجنسي
للاطفال عبر الانترنت
تستمر في الضغط لكشف المحتويات المخالفه
واتساب ترفض تهديد خصوصيه المستخدمين لميس
راح تكشف المزيد
تطبيقات القادره على التنصت
[موسيقى]
تتحدث مع صديقك حول شيء ما وما انتم سكه
هاتفك حتى تشاهد اعلانا لنفس الشيء امر
شائع اليس كذلك التفسير البديهي ان
هواتفنا تستمع الينا لكن المفاجاه ان ذلك
لا يحدث طبقا لكثير من خبراء التقنيه
وكبرى شركات التي تنكر ذلك في الواقع لا
تحتاج التطبيقات الى التنصت لمحادثاتك
لاظهار اعلان لمنتج او خدمه مات يكفيها ان
تتعرف على سجل البحث الخاص بك والمواقع
المفضله عاداتك في التسوق الالكتروني
المشتريات السابقه ثم مشاركه هذه
المعلومات مع المعلنين طيب ماذا نفعل حتى
نطمئن ببساطه يمكن ان نختار الا يصل
التطبيق لبعض خصوصياتنا الا وقت استخدامه
فقط في النهايه نحن من نسمح للتطبيقات
لتشغيل الكاميرا او الميكروفون او الوصول
الى معرض الصور والفيديوهات ومواقعنا يفضل
ايضا ان تاخذ الجوله في هاتفك وتحذف
التطبيقات التي لا تحتاجها ولم تستخدمها
لاشهر وفي حال لازلت لا تشعر بالراحه
يمكنك ببساطه تعطيل المساعد الصوتي سيري
او جوجل التي تستمع لمحادثتك ترقبا
للاستجابه وقت ما يتطلب منها ذلك
اي والله يا لميس هانا سيري ذبحتني تدخل
بكل شيء احد الا طلعت سيري سيري يسمونها
فيصل خلينا نعرف اكثر دواخل التطبيقات
اللي بتتنصت علينا يعني كيف بتم هاي
العمليه شو هي التطبيقات شو بنقدر نعمل
لحتى ننتبه انه للمايك ولا الكاميرا
مفتوحين واحنا مش عملنا بنستعمل تطبيقات
معينه
جميل جدا صبحكم الله بالخير يا زول يا رب
العالمين يسعد صباحك مشاهدين فعليا
التطبيقات لها صلاحيات تطلبها وهذا الامر
مع التحديثات الاخيره سنتين هذه الصلاحيات
كل مستخدم يعطي الصلاحيات اللي هو شوفها
صح لنفس التطبيق نلاقي ان التطبيقات زي
واتساب احنا نعطيها صلاحيه الوصول
للمايكروفون الكاميرا لجهات الاتصال
الموجوده عندي وايضا لالبوم الصور هذا
الشيء الطبيعي عشان تستخدم التطبيق الحين
لما نروح على سجل الرقم اللي صار فيه نفس
الجوال واللي طلع منه نفس الصوره اللي
طلعت على تويتر على حسب استخدام واتساب
المايكروفون هنا نعرف انه التطبيقات هل هي
ملتزمه للصلاحيات اللي انا اعطيتها اياها
في الاستخدام فقط في هذه الاوقات او لا
وكل المستخدمين نرجع للالف باء الاساسيه
امكانيات الصلاحيات بامكانكم تعطوها
وتعدلوها وتغيروها في اي لحظه وفي اي وقت
مع اي تطبيق في جوالاتكم فكل واحد فيكم
اذا مثلا الواتساب لا يمكن كنت قد يكون في
منه مشكله او في شك عن موضوع الواتساب
ادخل على التطبيق نفسه الصلاحيات يشيل عن
صلاحيه المايك يجي الصباح يرجع يرجع
صلاحيه المايك كذا ناخذها ببساطه الى ان
يبان فعليا المهندسين والاشياء الاساسيه
اللي قاعده تصير من تبعات هذه التغريبه ما
حتى حتى جوجل عاده بالسابق كانوا يقولون
انه والله يتصنت عليك يعني لماذا يتصنت
هذا التطبيق على سين او صاد الى هالدرجه
هذا راح يغير من مستقبل البشريه
جميل جدا
اي وداعات
بالضبط لانه هي مصلحه الجوال ومصلحه
التطبيقات ومصلحه الطرف التقني من الاجهزه
انه يحصل على قد ما يمكن من المنفعه مش من
الاسرار مو من المعلومات ومن الصور قد ما
يحصل على المنفعه من صاحب هذا الجوال بحيث
انه شراء ونفس دائره الاستهلاك تستمر سواء
يقعد يقترح لنا مواقع خدمات منتجات وما
يقدر يقترح هذه الاشياء الا لما يعرف
اطبعك وعوايدك ولسه احنا لازم ناكد انه
احنا بالنسبه للاجهزه اركان
اه هو اللي عم بتنصت علينا مش اشخاص هو
الالغريد بنفسه السيستم التطبيق نفسه بس
على كل حال فيصل كيف بنقدر نعرف بانه
الكاميرا او الميكروفون لتطبيق معين احنا
مش عم نستعمله حاليا في هاي اللحظه شغال
هل في هل في اشي بين يبين لنا اذا بتقدر
تشرح لنا خطوه بخطوه يعني
حلو اذا اي واحد من اجهزتكم الحين حاليا
على التحديثات الاخير على الايفون عندها
اندرويد وفيه هنا ايفون كل الاثنين موجوده
فاذا فتحتوا الكاميرا حتلاحظوا انه نفس
الكاميرا الحين صار يطلع لكم شعار فوق انه
الكاميرا شغاله وهذا الشعار اللي يطلع
الخضراء
نقطه صغيره موجوده فوق فضحت حاطين
تلفوناتنا يمنا
على
النقاط الصغيره سواء الحمراء او الخضراء
او البرتقاليه نقطه صغيره تلاقوها وهذا
الامر على الايفون وعلى كل اجهزه
الاندرويد مع اخر تحديث فهنا نعرف انه
الكاميرا يتم الوصول لها ولو سويتوا نفس
الشيء وفتحته مسجل الصوت حتلاقي يطلع لكم
لون ثاني من نفس النقطه وهذا الامر مبني
بين السوفت وير بين التطبيق وبين
البرمجيات وبين الهاردوير وبين العتاد هذا
الامر اخر سنتين هو اريح شيء لما نفتح اي
تطبيق ونلاقي طلع لنا احد هذه الثلاث نقاط
نعرف انه فيها في وصول كاميرا او
مايكروفون او وصول الى جهاز لنفسه اللهم
صل وسلم على محمد الاساسيه فبالتالي لما
ما نلاقي هذه النقطه ما في اي واحد قاعد
يحاول يوصل له هذا المستخدم وهنا نجي
للمشكله لاصدرت على واتساب في هذه
التغريده اذا كان يطلب المايكروفون ما طلع
هذه الاضاءه اذا في برمجيه مو
وهذه اللي من خلالها ولكن احنا في اخر
سنتين في مامن باذن واحد احد مع اتباع
النهج الصحيح جدا
بالمحصله النهائيه فيصل السيف يقول لكم
القرار بيدكم تقدر تروح على الاعدادات
وتشيل هذا
والتصريح اللي انت معطيه لهذا البرنامج
حتى يستخدم ميكروفونك وكاميرتك وصورك الى
اخره الامر بيدك وليس بيدك تطبيق شكرا
جزيلا فيصل السيف
المؤثر وصانع المحتوى والخبير التقليدي
يعطيك الف عافيه